if there's one thing i've come to hate
about pseudoscience cures
is their abhorrent cost it's not bad
enough that they're selling empty
promises and fake cures
no to add insult to injury these
treatments are oftentimes more expensive
than a simple
otc or prescription that actually treats
the condition
how they manage to up charge something
as plentiful and inexpensive as water is
beyond me
it covers 70 percent of the earth and
falls from the [ __ ] sky
and yet you charge almost 30 bucks for a
whole gallon i'll buy three cases of
cheap box wine for 30 bucks before i buy
a gallon of alkaline water
besides why is alkaline water so damn
expensive
perhaps it's from an undiscovered spring
in south america
no is it frozen ice water that's found
on the moon melted bottled and then
chipped back to earth
no there's nothing special about it it's
just
water it's as expensive as it is because
of industry deception and frankly
consumer ignorance
luckily in this video i can at least
reduce this by enlightening you the
consumer
people buy alkaline water for reasons
they buy other health-minded goods
like avocados or wild-caught salmon
because they're known to be good for
your health
the benefits of healthy food in the long
term outweighs the high price so people
are willing to shell out money for
it however unlike avocados or wild
caught salmon
alkaline water offers no measurable
health benefits than the same water that
comes from your faucet
generally speaking there are two widely
held beliefs associated with drinking
alkaline water that are flat out wrong
firstly that alkaline water has
antioxidant properties
case in point here are six benefits of
drinking
alkaline water as alkaline water is
loaded with antioxidants today we're
going to talk about antioxidants now
it's a big word key properties of
alkaline ionized water
and that is the fact that this water is
a very powerful
antioxidant but actually ionized water
contains anywhere from two to five times
as many antioxidants the second belief
is that alkaline water adjusts your
body's ph
but we'll get to this later firstly
alkaline water is supposedly plentiful
with antioxidants
here's the thing if you want to be
healthy avoid cancer or just live a long
life
antioxidants are the way to go the
reason antioxidants are great for your
health is that they inhibit harmful
chemical reactions
inside your body what kind of harmful
reactions you ask
well first let's think of this inside a
test tube you have a molecule that under
certain circumstances its chemical bonds
break and it loses an electron
when it loses an electron it becomes a
free radical which is very reactive
free radicals just about attack any
nearby molecule and steal their
electrons to stabilize itself
which is kind of good the only problem
is when a free radical steals an
electron from a nearby molecule
it makes that molecule into a free
radical
for example free radical a steals from
molecule b
free radical a is now a stable molecule
but molecule b
is then turned into free radical b free
radical b
steals from molecule c free radical b
turns into a molecule but now molecule c
is free radical c
this goes on and on making a chain
reaction
the way that you stop this chain
reaction from happening is to add an
antioxidant to the reaction itself
the antioxidant due to its molecular
structure is able to donate electrons to
free radicals without themselves
becoming free radicals
providing an electron to a free radical
quenches the chain reaction
here's the thing a lot of antioxidants
are actually vitamins
such as vitamin a c and e this is why
niacin is a common ingredient in stored
food
niacin is actually vitamin b and vitamin
b
being an antioxidant prevents these
chain reactions from happening that
would otherwise cause the food to spoil
now imagine this whole scenario in the
test tube is happening inside your body
your body naturally produces free
radicals it's just a part of living
and as you probably guessed free
radicals wreak havoc on your body
causing aging sickness and increases the
risk for cancer
when you eat foods high in antioxidants
such as carotenoids
anthocyans and catechins you introduce
antioxidants to your body which reduce
the amount of free radicals
this is why it's important to consume
fruit and vegetables on a daily basis
sorry for the tangent back to alkaline
water antioxidants found in these fruits
and vegetables
are not in alkaline water in fact
there's no antioxidants in it at all
see okay that's not real but there
really aren't any antioxidants in
alkaline water
the ingredients added to most alkaline
water is just mineral and salts
specifically calcium chloride potassium
bicarbonate and magnesium sulfate
i researched six different brands of
alkaline water
and 5 out of 6 or 83 percent only had
mineral additives
and no vitamins or antioxidants
whatsoever
pause it and take a look for yourself
only one had a non-mineral ingredient
fulvic acid which is a class of organic
acids and minerals
extracted from soil so again no
antioxidants
the minerals in alkaline water are only
there to make the ph
more alkaline so this as alkaline water
is loaded with antioxidants
is [ __ ] by the way the home ionizers
that you use to make your own alkaline
water are no different
they just add these minerals and salts
to your tap water so basically
a waste of money here's the good news if
you want a healthy drink with
antioxidants you can buy fruit smoothie
drinks
and they're much less costly than
alkaline water disclaimer
i'm in no way paid or affiliated with
any kind of fruit drink companies so
this is not a paid advertisement
but check this out right when you look
at the nutritional facts you immediately
know it's full of healthy antioxidants
such as vitamin c vitamin e niacin
vitamin b6 vitamin b12 and pantothenic
acid
i'm not sure what this is but it sounds
pretty healthy and just look at those
daily milligram values
as opposed to now the second popular
belief of alkaline water is that it
balances your body's ph
that is if your body was somehow in an
acidic state
drinking alkaline water would raise the
ph back to normal
or that flat out drinking it raises your
body's ph to a more alkaline level
making it less conducive for cancer
apparently so
it's really really important in order to
get rid of these free radicals
to first alkalize the body one of the
easiest ways to do this
is through alkaline water when you drink
alkaline water
you put yourself in an alkaline state
what this is also very false
the human body does not have fluctuating
ph levels
ph is tightly regulated in a very short
range between 7.35
and 7.45 if it's ever outside this range
it's potentially fatal
but hold on what is ph is the measure of
how acidic or alkalinity solution is
relative to a scale from
1 to 14. if it's between 1 and 6 it's
acidic
and if it's between 8 and 14 it's
alkaline
for example the ph of hydrochloric acid
a notoriously strong acid is 1.
on the other end bleach a very strong
alkaline solution has a ph of 12.
vinegar has a ph of 4 water a ph of 7
and
human blood a ph of 7.4 and wouldn't you
know it
having such a specific ph the body
became very efficient at maintaining
this
tight ph range you see throughout the
day you do things that affect the ph of
your blood
one example is running when you run your
blood becomes acidic so the ph
drops below 7.4 the more you exercise
the more your cells use atp than
mitochondria
and thereby produce more carbon dioxide
when carbon dioxide is in the blood it
becomes carbonic acid which makes your
blood acidic
in order to raise your ph back to 7.4
your body makes you breathe faster
so you exhale more carbon dioxide and
thereby remove more carbonic acid from
your blood
returning your blood ph to the safe
range you can drink a bottle of alkaline
water but
ultimately the body is going to keep
your ph set at this range
it's not like your ph is 7.2 and
drinking alkaline water will help raise
it back to 7.4
no it was already at 7.4 because it
needs to be there
thinking alkaline water will change your
blood ph is like throwing an ice cube
onto a grill to lower the temperature
it just isn't significant enough to do
anything at this point
if you're an alkaline water advocate or
you spent over a hundred dollars on a
home ionizer you probably don't like me
right about now
in fact you may be saying well what
about these scientific studies that show
how good alkaline water is for your body
well it turns out that i did in fact
read these same studies so let's see
what they say
the first is a 2016 study from the
evidence-based complementary and
alternative medicine
journal the study compared three groups
of mice 50 mice per group
mice in group a received alkaline water
from an ionizer
group b received in-house made alkaline
water and group c received regular water
from the tap
the mice were studied with the three
separate water conditions over a three
year period
after three years the mice were compared
for differences mice groups a and b
on average had lower mortality rates and
showed less signs of aging
in kidney intestine heart liver and
brain tissue samples
whereas with group c they had higher
mortality rates and more signs of aging
in their tissue samples
so does this mean that alkaline water is
actually good for you
well not necessarily one important piece
of information that the study failed to
include
was the specific diet the mice received
over the three year period
with the only diet information being
that they were fed conventionally
knowing what the mice ate is an
important factor was the mouse diet
lacking vital minerals that the mice
typically
need that is given regular tap water and
mouse chow would the mice have gotten
their recommended dose of required
minerals
the study doesn't say it's entirely
possible that groups a and b
the ones that receive the alkaline water
had a higher mineral intake
than the mice receiving tap water recall
alkaline water is alkaline because it
contains minerals such as calcium
carbonate and magnesium sulfate among
others
if the chao had no or little mineral
supply that means that groups a and b
were getting more mineral intake from
the alkaline water while the tap mice
water were not
this doesn't mean that alkaline water
improves your health
it just means that one set of mice
received mineral supplements and the
other did not
in a different study this time involving
humans researchers had two groups of
participants do an exercise till they
became moderately dehydrated
for group 1 they gave them standard tap
water and for group 2 they gave them
alkaline water
blood samples were taken from both
groups and were tested for differences
researchers discovered that group 2 the
group that drank alkaline water had a
lower blood viscosity than group 1.
viscosity is the measure of how thick a
liquid is
syrup is very viscous whereas water is
not
generally for your blood the less
viscosity the better alkaline water
reduced blood viscosity
more than tap water so surely alkaline
ph played a role
except for one small tiny little problem
in a completely different study the same
phenomenon occurred with participants
who drank gatorade
in this study participants were also
separated into two groups
and underwent dehydration group 1 drank
gatorade
and group 2 drink tap water group 1 was
revealed to have lower blood viscosity
than group 2.
what's actually pretty funny is that
gatorade does not have an alkaline ph at
all
in fact it's pretty acidic with a ph of
3. how is it that something acidic such
as gatorade was able to reduce blood
viscosity i thought the whole point of
alkaline water
making blood less viscous was the fact
that it's alkaline
well turns out the ph did not cause the
blood viscosity to change
it was the electrolytes in the drink
electrolytes such as magnesium
calcium potassium and others are present
in both drinks
which is what changed the blood
viscosity what's more is a bottle of
gatorade is cheaper than a bottle of
alkaline water
and also it tastes better too but that's
just my opinion
lemon lime you're calling my name so it
would seem that alkaline water really
has no grounds for being any different
than regular tap water or gatorade for
that matter
it doesn't contain any antioxidants and
it cannot adjust your blood ph
overall on the stupid scale i'm giving
alkaline water a 6 out of 10
and on the harmful scale a 3 out of 10.